Reus Now in
ncel volume Herbie player plus
jsr One leaf supple
press die x hot
drug crude oil It's probably better
to come to Seventeen's concert at age 4 It
's good to come to Seoul, which is a dull concert But let me lead
it What is Gyeongbokgung or something like
this tradition
Wouldn't it be nice to go to some places where you can experience something else?
Dr. 4 thinks more
Wow, hey, but this
training is located. x Plus
I remember when I wrote that kite, the members went to the
Han River, it's probably just a
natural thing. At that time,
I came to play the 3rd basketball for the members as well. That's why I went
first
And one dimension, there was a time when we were on a diet when we were trainees,
so early on,
we all remembered that we were together for a few hours
.
We were
playing with each other despite not being able to play in the first lecture, but
now you guys have to stand in front of the public, so
dance here.
I think that was the point.
Now, anyway, we
get a lot of our stage sets. Now, how do we get a lot of
center and stuff like this? Now
that it's a language, you say you
see a little bit of
that.
You see, I
've helped now I u Recently,
as a person who rides a lot on the Han River,
I think it's time to be short and
careful. Ride a bike Riding a bike in Apgujeong
Garosu-
gil.
Once in a place where the atmosphere attracts you
I would also recommend going, but
maybe it’s Irving who is a traveler
Hive is recommended
90g Grow a little here,
it says to prevent it Oh, we
also saw the Hive Insight Museum and it worked so well, and now it’s going well so
that many people can enjoy it
.
There are 4 parts and 4 throughout the temple, so it's
just
full 4
xe nun so I'm not a
fan of any church
For chicken feet, I recommend going to
some kind of market where you've been working for a long time and
try some 2
That 's funny , it 's gotten worse
Tteokbokki chicken feet in the dong First of all, the taste is
very
sweet and the smell is
unique to the place
. There are games like naejo and sundae like this, but the food
together is a lot of team combination, so yes, the responsibility is in the
chicken broth.  I still had to take a dip, so I still
wore a mask while still wearing it.
It's really all people, so it's easy
to find in Korea. So you
have to be smart to be really spicy these days
.
I always go home. When the tteokbokki shop is all out, the
maid is there, but it’s a corporation. Smile
No.2 Diva Quest
, Gamjatang Bass Cu, there’s nothing a year or so,
one-person Q Magpie La sr Rice on
wii
side man.
I'll sleep when I wake up  And now
, after looking in the mirror, I can
do a lot, but I’m going to say a little more.
Why do these prices go up?
That squid sesame hurts 4
So,
Dalgona Because there is a boom in Dalgona around the world, we have
to ride the Chauceo adaptation of the end
.
As a
result, dalgona does not taste just like sugar.
Chom I have a little bit of baking soda mixed in.
102 I'm lying down and
conveying that appropriate port language.
It feels a bit disparaging. Ayane Give me some hamburgers
.
There
are a lot of things that are run, so it’s terrorism, etc.
Milkshake tastes like this, because it tastes like the road, so it’s the
last one.
You know it
’s mine with a hamburger.
Those people who are now reinterpreting the foods of that country
from now on,
it is fun to compare them while looking at sleeping or
fasting.  I drink a lot both at home and at home and at Chinese food, and
I drink a lot, and there's a threat
sievest ss in the mouth Anne
Bernie de B. short burn 3 Tiscents ahhh
[music]